Wi-Fi, the technology that promised to
connect us to everything and spends most
of its time connecting us to absolutely
nothing. We put a man on the moon with
less computing power than your router.
And yet that router can't hold a signal
for 20 ft. But your bathroom door,
impenetrable fortress. And don't get me
started on passwords. capital letter,
number, special character. Your mother's
maiden name spelled backwards, a sworn
oath. At some point, you're just typing
random keystrokes, hoping the internet
gods accept your offering. Then there's
your printer. Low can, you're printing
black text. Why do you need cyan? Is
there a cyan party happening inside this
machine? Your phone buzzed 80 times
today. You needed three of those
notifications. Your attention span
didn't shrink. It was stolen by design.
We optimized everything and somehow
everything takes more time. Want to know
why?